i just want to put good music out you
know
[Music]
that of course is casey musgraves and
the award-winning follow your arrow the
breakout hit
off her major label debut album same
trailer different park
that song broke barriers in the country
industry
as it was all about celebrating who you
are despite
others perceptions something we don't
see often
in the genre and of course casey stunned
everyone with her message of support to
the lgbtq plus community
when she sang this lyric
[Music]
she said it best during her cma awards
acceptance speech for
song of the year when she proudly
announced do you guys realize what this
means for country music
back in 2014 it was a big deal that the
country music association
recognized a song with such a
progressive message
and we are so happy casey took that risk
it paved the way for more inclusivity
and acceptance in the genre and she
continues to be
an outspoken ally now in celebration of
pride month i caught up with casey's
co-writers
and openly gay artists brandy clark and
shane mcinally who looked back
on the success of the song admitting
they didn't know the impact
it would have on the industry for years
to come that was a situation where
um i didn't feel like we were doing
anything
all that big or special you know but
that song
means more to more people than probably
anything else
i've been associated with the biggest
thing is the way it continues to live on
people will come up to me and when they
find out that i was a part of that song
it's such a big deal to so many people
and so it's
something i'm really proud to to have
been a part of
it means so much to me i get emotional
about it and especially that i wrote it
with those two ladies
over the years it has taken on more and
more and more meaning
when we wrote it we weren't trying to
piss people off
and it was just casey has this idea
follow your arrow
i i i know when she first came up with
it it wasn't about
gay people yeah it was about everyone
and it was a you know it was just
inclusivity
she was getting a lot of judgment uh
early on because she wasn't like
everybody else
they expect something from females in
music
especially country music they expect for
them to put on
a certain facade oh yeah and that's what
they that's what they want from them
everything is all right now
women have had to go through a similar
you know
situation as what we are going through
now where they have to
hide a little it's like i'm a girl but
i'm a cool girl
and casey doesn't play that and um
she's always been such an inspiration to
me she's
you know she's what 17 years younger
than me and i've always felt like she
was teaching me
i think it's safe to say casey is an
inspiration to
all of us and when i caught up with her
way back in 2013
i asked her if she was afraid of what
the response to the song might be
the things that i think about aren't you
know they aren't big deals to me
uh i don't really think that they should
beat anyone else i think it's just life
and um we all live it and we're all
inspired by
we're all driven by the same emotions
you know gay straight black white
whatever it is and it's like
it's only a big deal if you make it a
big deal